wait for this i thi this is really
intense right here um so uh everyone
welcome to HTML comp 2000 can everyone
see my screen okay awesome so um I was
explaining to a very good friend of mine
former co-worker why I was not in New
Jersey yesterday and I said that I was
additional cough which she said so it's
like the Tom Hanks the web dev
conferences which is now the new
official tagline of d HTML com so we
also have Tom Hanks is a sponsor so yeah
I curated this thing Michael had me come
out March of 1999 to speak at the
first-ever d HTML cough which was in San
Francisco so now we're like bicoastal
right and so I had given a talk called
malware injection proof your front-end
code in three easy steps or D HTML
ancestors don't want us to know about
and we had like some scheduling issues
and we had some extra time and he's like
well why don't you just give that talk
again so we can record it and I was like
yeah that's a good idea but a lot has
happened since March so I figured I'd
updated a bit but just to go through a
couple of things I taught in march was
the shipper wave web development which
is something that I feel like is
everyone's goal as a developer sort of
our endgame for why we create apps and
web development so I always try to
remember these different facets of it
but there's definitely a threat to the
shipper wave of development and that is
primarily malware malware is
counterproductive to this design pattern
it's a waste of time it causes us to
lose money resources it makes our web
brings not look so cool if all the
sudden Chrome's telling you that there's
you know malware on it and it's
especially rampant
those of us who develop with HTML which
makes sense being that the d stands for
dangerous and in America HTML is
something that has been plaguing our
teens and ourselves and we just don't
know that much about it obviously so
it's time that we start focusing more on
malware and getting rid of it and
preventing it and those are really only
the three simple steps to making sure
that our d HTML content isn't full of
gross pneus so fine how do you find
malware will you ask someone to do that
how do you get rid of it you delete it
and how do you prevent it and this is
another thing that I introduced back in
March and that's called the virus method
for preventing malware in our code so
for vaccination we make our sites look
like the site is already infected with
malware so like this is this is this is
back when I worked at the NBA and this
is what the NBA site look like you could
also put a virus on your site already
because nobody is going to infect your
site if it's already infected that's
crazy it's like if you have the flu the
flu is not going to get you at the same
time that just doesn't happen
interrogation I introduced this concept
earlier year called to ask a cop method
because we all know that if you ask a
cop if they're a cop they have to tell
you here's some JavaScript
so basically you just say like are you
malware and like the Malheur has to say
yes or no and then you just follow suit
recursion is just passing work on to
another computer if you don't have a
master's in computer science like I do
this is probably a little bit too
difficult of the concept but I created a
bookmarklet where you can just put your
site into the bookmarklet and then when
they click the bookmarklet the site
shows up on the page so it's also really
good we're like you don't have to worry
about dealing with putting your site on
the clouds and stuff like that you can
also use w3schools to show your site by
giving snippet of code to them and then
they can go into the try it yourself
editor and put the code in there and
then you see your site right over here
so also you're like avoiding clouds and
therefore like you're not paying for
things and that's just really useful in
w3schools isn't going anywhere as far as
I know there are other things that you
can do avoiding different types of file
extensions I had reasons for this but I
don't know but just trust me don't use
vim use HTM instead of HTML because
there was really no malware on sites
back when we've used HTM so I think that
that L kind of like things up for
us and then finally confused malware
because there's an S and virus or
whatever framesets if your site's full
of framesets there's more places for
malware to have to try to find some more
frames that you have in your page the
harder it is your cool horizontal
scrolling so horizontal scrolling that
like photographers love this like it's
really hard to like access that as a
human so like if a human can't access it
or if you use non semantic tags and like
machine can't read it then like you
don't have to worry about viruses trying
to read it image only development is
also something that I introduced
personally over the past year and it's
if your site's just an image then the
malware can't go anywhere so you really
should just start using images
everywhere which one of my talks
that we're going to have today involves
like pixels and that's those are an
images so it should be good and use
entities instead of tags so you don't
have to have like less than greater than
symbols in your HTML just use entities
and yeah you're going to see HTML on the
page but we're all developers we know
what that turns into so yeah so I
introduced the shipper way the virus
method and talked about how we should be
serious about malware but none of you
listened because here we are today and
the world is still full of malware and
I'm really used to people like listening
to what I say so I'm a little ticked off
right now so that's why the rest of my
talk now is the state of the malware and
I'm going to give you some examples of
malware that we've encountered this year
and then hopefully you can take this
information and go home and take a long
hard look in the mirror and be ashamed
of yourselves so horribly heartbleed um
was this malware and open SSL it's I
don't know it has a nice logo secrets
were leaked that was in cool shell shock
the new order album that came out in 86
I thought that they were remastering but
like it turns out that has nothing to do
with new order
it was this like vulnerability in bash
ExtremeTech called it a deadly new
vulnerability I don't know what was
updated about it but all I know is it
sounded scary what was leave probably
secrets I don't know I'm running that
time so I'm gonna not going to go
through the rest of these other so here
we are today here we are today at the
HTML comp 2000 and it's this has been
this is the first time back in March
that I gave us at arikil talk and I'm
here in front of you giving a serious
one but I feel I feel like I've got five
awesome speakers and talk to you about a
whole variety of things pixels Jurassic
Park came up I saw Jurassic Park and
said yes I don't care what it's about
ariat subculture in the early 2000s a
whole bunch of awesome stuff SEO which
is probably the most important when I
had announced on Twitter I don't know if
you heard of it but I said I was like
I'm so excited to curate d HTML calm
conference where I gave my first arikil
talk Allah and this guy um he brought up
this question and turned into like a six
month campaign about it about whether
satire is ruining JavaScript and so I'm
here today to ruin javascript and and
I'm glad that all of you here are here
to help ruin javascript with me and to
show that this needs to happen there are
some really important people in
JavaScript that have saved that tweet
they're excited like my friend Angus
Florida Potch I know that guy is Matt my
coworker so this is really something
that needs to happen and events like
this sort of super cool because really
we just all want to have fun while we're
injecting malware until all of our sites
so thank you for being here our first
talk is going to be my pal Pavel so
pretend that he mends playing on the
screen and
enjoy geesh knock off